pères accusent les gendarmes doute la
victime avait 13 ans et demi verdict
attendu ce soir dans le procès de la
branche lyonnaise d'action directe la
cour a entendu cet après-midi la
plaidoirie de maître vergès qui a
concédé quoiqu'il europe interpelle les
commentateurs après le compromis de
madrid sur l'union monétaire
en direct de bruxelles dans ce journal
jacques delors
la tradition du grand portage sous le
regard de lénine c'est le titre du
magazine quand n 2 consacre ce soir à
l'union soviétique de gorbatchev
étonnant et détonnant madame monsieur
bonsoir
un garçon de 13 ans et demi tué d'une
balle en pleine tête 7 et hier soir près
de grenoble
les éléments du drame c'est presque trop
simple il y à la vie difficile d'un
ferrailleur qui a installé sa casse sur
un terrain qui ne lui appartient pas
deux enfants qui l'élève seule à la dure
il y a le harcèlement qu'ils subissent
depuis des années de la part d'inconnus
les fusils sont souvent sorti à champs
sur drac
hier il y a eu un coup de trop
aujourd'hui le père accuse les
propriétaires du terrain menacent de
s'immoler sur place pour antenne de
bruno roger petit robert cyr où les
pieds dans une bassine d'essence et
menaçant de s'immoler par le feu père
désespéré
laurent son fils david tué d'une balle
en pleine tête après la véritable
bataille rangée qui a opposé hier pierre
siro et ses deux fils à des agresseurs
masqués et armés
depuis le temps qu'ils avaient déjà tout
à m'en faire côté vous avez vous le dis
depuis des années robert six roues est
assiégé voitures incendiées menaces
coups de feu à l'entendre les coupables
ne sont autres que les membres de la
famille selon les propriétaires du
terrain sur lequel il vit et qui veulent
landais loger coûte que coûte
tu m'en veux selon ya pas de problème
mon projet on apprend que la gendarmerie
a libéré les selon entier les a libérés
c'est qu'ils sont pas coupables
ils ont fourni les alibis car robert cyr
ou ne supporte pas que les selon accusée
par lui est été entendu puis relâché par
les gendarmes de vizille les selon
ennemis irréductibles de robert siro qui
sortent rarement de leur maison aux
volets clos
fernand le chef de clan déterminé à
reprendre sa terre à robert cyr où il
nie tout l'avocat demande à voir quel
est votre alibi exactement quel est
votre alibi que faisiez-vous hier
lorsqu'il ya eu l'incident là bas
pour traduire la faille un gp est mis
dès hier dès 8 heures du soir
oh vous êtes avec vos enfants non je
vous et à montreuil est assez juste le
bon travailler et vos enfants était où
si tous les membres de la famille selon
ont apparemment un alibi en béton alors
qu'ils avaient intérêt à chasser d'un
terrain vague et par tous les moyens
un homme de 60 ans et ses deux enfants
un peu marginaux pour le moment le
mystère reste entier
mais ce soir les gendarmes n'excluaient
pas d'entendre à nouveau tous les
membres de la famille selon pour
complément d'information le bicentenaire
et le tourisme
il y a aujourd'hui deux versions la
première du ministère du tourisme qui
prévoit une augmentation du nombre des
visiteurs en france il serait notamment
alléchés par la fête à la gloire de la
révolution
les professionnels du voyage préfère
peut considérer que l'année 1989 devrait
être une bonne année mais pas
spécialement en raison du bicentenaire
dépliants et des tailles avec elisabeth
engeler paris connaît ses derniers
moments de tranquillité
dès la semaine prochaine la bastille et
bien d'autres quartiers vont être pris
d'assaut principalement par les
visiteurs étrangers
en juillet on en attend 35 % de plus que
les années passées cela s'inscrit dans
une progression exceptionnelle du
tourisme en france qui devrait rapporter
au moins 30 milliards de francs alors
qu'il avait raconté 25 l'an dernier et
20 il ya deux ans c'est un chiffre qui
est plus important que ce que rapporte
désormais l'automobile par exemple la
france
touristes plus nombreux allemands et
anglais en tête et aussi séjours plus
longs
de quoi réjouir les hôteliers parisiens
qui affiche complet pour la période du
13 au 17 juillet en revanche 70% dès
agents de voyages estiment que les
festivités auront peu de répercussion
pour eux faute d'une bonne organisation
et les programmes de manifestations à
l'occasion du bicentenaire ont été
connus vers le mois d'octobre novembre
et voir plus tard il faut bien savoir
que les brochures des voyagistes
étrangers sortent au mois de juillet ou
de septembre de l'année précédente et
que donc il était trop tard pour pour
inclure un certain nombre de
manifestations dans leur programme
france malgré tout 89 sera une bonne
année pour tous le tourisme français
grâce au bicentenaire mais aussi à la
remontée du dollar
une bonne année suivie d'autres bonne
année car les retombées devraient se
faire sentir jusqu'en 92
la france est paraît-il à la mode le
génie ne s'est pas revêtu d'or pour rien
dans le même contexte nous avons
également des canons de 20 mm qui font
beaucoup parler pour protéger le sommet
des pays industrialisés la mi juillet
prochain
l'armée de l'air souhaite installer une
batterie sur le pont de tolbiac 7 à
paris jacques chirac n'est pas contre
mais préférerait que ce soit ailleurs le
maire de paris estime que la circulation
sera déjà suffisamment difficile
sans cela le rend boussier un canon
antiaérien de 20 mm installé sur le pont
de tolbiac pour protéger le secteur
opéra bastille contre un avion léger
venant de la scène
ce pourrait être un des moyens de
défense et de sécurité de la capitale
pendant les festivités du bicentenaire
et le sommet des pays industrialisés
un moyen parmi d'autres pour interdire
aux adeptes du baron noir et autres
perturbateurs de venir troubler la
quiétude des chefs d'état mais assurer
la sécurité la défense d'une zone
urbaine n'est pas simple deux espaces
aériens l'un complètement interdit
d'autres réservés aux appareils
autorisés seront définies dans le ciel
de la capitale pour les surveiller six
radars supplémentaires viendront
s'ajouter aux quatre déjà chargé du
contrôle des mouvements d'avions et
d'hélicoptères
des guetteurs munis de jumelles à
infrarouge et des caméra pouvant filmer
la nuit seront installés sur les points
hauts de la capitale enfin d unité de
défense anti aérienne et des
hélicoptères prêts à intervenir seront
placés dans la région parisienne secret
défense oblige aucune information sur le
nombre de ses armes ou le lieu de leur
implantation n'a été publié c'est
l'armée de l'air qui sera chargé de
l'ensemble de ces mesures
les mêmes qui avaient été prises en 1982
pour le sommet de versailles et en 1984
pour l'anniversaire du débarquement
allié en normandie
des mesures lourdes qui servent surtout
à sécuriser les délégations étrangères
toujours soucieuse de leur sécurité
politique avec un sondage sofres figaro
magazine et un vainqueur monsieur
giscard d'estaing qui gagne en un mois
quatre points avec 49% de satisfaits
madame veil -le père 19 points avec
seulement 36 % d'avis favorables 4
points de baisse pour le président
mitterrand à 58% de satisfaits 3 points
en moins à 62 % de satisfaction pour
michel rocard
laurent fabius perd 11 points à 44%
sondage réalisé après après les
européennes à l'assemblée l'opposition
demande d commission denquête sur les
rapports de l'exécutif et du judiciaire
et sur la sphère lüscher l'argumentation
et de bernard pons
la défense est assurée par michel rocard
qui évoque le non-lieu et l'intégrité du
juge dans la sphère lüscher
petite difficulté devions avoir un
extrait de l'intervention de michel
rocard cet après midi à l'assemblée dans
les questions je suis musulman car
estimé que le juge le grand dans la
sphère du cher avait parfaitement fait
son travail qu'il avait eu tous les
éléments du dossier et donc s'il avait
rendu un non-lieu c'est qu'il n'avait
aucune autre possibilité de poursuivre
plus loin son action nous allons donc
continuer l'actualité en parlant de la
chine où le combat continue pour les
étudiants de l'étranger ou sur cassette
les leaders du mouvement appelle à la
continuation de la lutte il y a
également à pékin publication du
discours complet de deng xiaoping après
après la reprise en main sur le thème
non aux contre-révolutionnaires
oui encore aux capitaux étrangers bruno
le dresse le visage est triste le ton
mélancolique
j'ignore combien de martyrs sont tombés
dans les rues de pékin
puisse-t-il reposer en paix murmure-t-il
et il ajoute ce gouvernement tombera
définitivement ce ne sera pas long la
réapparition de where kaixi est un pied
de nez aux autorités à l'armée et à la
police chinoise qui le cherchait
activement
c'était l'un des trois leaders du
mouvement étudiant le plus charismatique
le plus cabotin sur la place tiananmen
son talent d'orateur faisait merveille
grévistes de la faim qui l'interpellent
a violemment li peng le premier ministre
venu s'enquérir de sa santé
chaque jour la télévision montrer ces
images de lui filmé à son insu le
commentateur invitant la population à le
dénoncer
il figurait en seconde position sur la
liste des étudiants recherché pourtant
il a réussi à s'échapper tout comme
cette jeune femme aileen responsable de
l'occupation de la place tiananmen qu'on
vient d'apprendre qu'elle est réfugié en
australie
mais en chine c'est nsia au ping qui
occupe les médias aujourd'hui on a
publié le texte intégral de son discours
au chef de l'armée
c'est désormais la référence la base de
travail sur laquelle doit s'appuyer tout
la politique chinoise avec deux mots
d'ordre quelque peu contradictoire
ouverture économique
conservatisme politique c'est la ligne
que suivra la chine tant que son vieux
leader restera au pouvoir au japon il y
a désormais une nouvelle race d'hommes
politiques
le dirigeant en sursis on disait
monsieur uno qui a succédé en extrême
urgence à monsieur takeshita chassé par
le scandale routes sûres et sans
reproche
pas sûr même s'il dément il est embourbé
dans une histoire de geisha à qui il
aurait payé plusieurs millions de yens
ses faveurs la dame témoigne assez
largement non pas de sa virilité mais de
sa goujaterie
monsieur ou non et donc à son tour en
sursis il viendra quand même à paris
représentait le japon ou sommet des pays
industrialisés qui a concédé quoi à qui
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose tous les commentateurs politiques
après le compromis de madrid sur l'union
monétaire margaret thatcher a fait
quelques concessions
mais aussitôt rentré à londres elle a
réaffirmé que de toute façon elle ne
céderait pas sur l'essentiel
ni monnaie européenne ni banque centrale
commune invitée de ce journal monsieur
de leur président de la commission
bruxelles monsieur de l'or le
dessinateur plantu vous fait dire à la
une du monde cet après midi nous avons
décidé à l'unanimité moins une voix que
l'une d'entre nous commençait à nous
gonfler sérieusement je cite bien sûr
est ce que ceux ci recouvre trivialement
et de loin votre approche du premier
ministre britannique monsieur de l'or
non pas du tout je pense que l'europe
est une famille avec douze pays
lorsque dans la famille certains pensent
avoir gagné et d'autres pensent avoir
perdu c'est la famille ensemble qui perd
or à madryn
l'europe a continué d'avancer voyez vous
il faut considérer l'europe non pas
comme une photo mais comme un film
et si j'ai une minute rappelez vous il y
a 6 ans l'europe perdait six cent mille
emplois par an l'année dernière elle en
a créé un million huit cent mille ya six
ans l'europe avait un faible taux de
croissance un ennemi pour cent par an
maintenant plus de 3%
il y a 6 ans ils étaient des raies
difficile un étudiant d'aller faire ses
études dans un autre pays
maintenant il ya des programmes qui
permettent aux étudiants européens
d'aller passer une partie de leurs
études dans d'autres pays de faire des
stages dans
entreprise il y a 6 ans il y avait déjà
le système monétaire européen monde lui
donnait pas cher de son avenir
aujourd'hui il est conforté il est
devenu une zone de stabilité
il faut voir l'europe comme un film oui
justement ce film ce que vous n'êtes
cité c'est du positif mais madame
margaret thatcher concède l'entrée de la
livre dans le système monétaire européen
mais en n'allant pas au delà est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'elle
gagne du temps pour mieux vous combattre
vous puisque vous êtes à l'origine de
l'union économique et monétaire
oui mais c'est aussi le film il y a deux
mois
madame thatcher rejeter le rapport qui
porte mon nom en dit dans ce n'est pas
notre conception de l'europe
il ya deux jours elle a accepté d'entrer
dans le processus de ce rapport elle a
accepté la première étape il en est
toujours ainsi
nous progressons et nous irons jusqu'au
bout pourquoi parce que l'europe ça
marche parce que d'autres pays veulent
adhérer parce que l'union soviétique les
états unis nous considèrent maintenant
avec beaucoup d'attention
donc le mouvement entraîne le mouvement
le succès en prennent le succès gérard
leclerc avec jacques delors tout de même
ses refus répétés ces désaccords de fond
avec la grande bretagne ne peut-il pas
pour ce qu'on appelle parfois une europe
à géométrie variable c'est-à-dire aller
plus loin dans l'intégration européenne
uniquement avec les pays qui le veulent
qu'ils en ont la volonté politique
bien sûr cette menace est toujours
présente mais c'est ça fait partie de ce
qui nous fait avancer
et d'autre part le sommet de madrid n'a
pas permis non plus d'avancer sur un
certain nombre de dossiers notamment sur
l'europe sociale ou l'harmonisation
fiscale est ce que finalement ce n'est
pas la vision libérale 7 chériennes
d'une europe simple zone de libre
échange en train de l'emporter sur les
tenants d'une véritable communauté
européenne
écoutez quand on double les ressources
que l'on consacre aux régions les plus
pauvres de la communauté pour le
développement de nos régions rurales
pour l'insertion des jeunes dans la vie
professionnelle pour la lutte contre le
chômage de longue durée est ce que c'est
la conception thatchérienne de l'europe
non c'est une conception qui correspond
à nos traditions
une europe équilibré où il n'y a pas de
progrès économique sans progrès social
mais s'il n'ya pas concertation et
progrès social alors le progrès
économique s'arrête
et même si madame thatcher a refusé
encore hier
de s'associer aux onze autres pays pour
une déclaration solennelle des droits
des travailleurs elle n'en a pas moins
accepté et signé un communiqué qu' vos
instructions à la commission et au
conseil des ministres de présenter un
nouveau programme de travail sur les
questions sociales avant la fin de
l'année chez de leurs la france prend la
présidence de la communauté pour six
mois à partir de samedi à partir du 1er
juillet quels progrès peut-on en
attendre
quel rôle peut jouer la france dans la
construction européenne dans ses six
mois de présidence notamment en ce qui
concerne la charte sociale la dernière
présidence française a été un grand
succès rappelez-vous en 1984 pendant
cinq ans l'europe étaient enfermés dans
ces disputes de famille grâce à l'action
de françois mitterrand on n'a pu
résoudre 12 problème qui faisait
division entre nous et c'est grâce à
cela que nous avons pu relancer la
construction européenne donc on attend
beaucoup de la présidence française
et je pense qu'elle va avancer dans le
domaine économique et monétaire en
mettant en oeuvre cette première phase
en mettant également en application ce
nouveau programme social dont je viens
de parler en faisant progresser l'europe
de l'audiovisuel c'est à dire
l'encouragement aux productions
européennes à nos cultures et à nos
langues
voilà je crois déjà un bon programme si
vous ajoutez à cela que c'est sous
présidence française que l'on signera la
convention avec les pays d'afrique des
caraïbes et du pacifique que nous allons
offrir une coopération meilleur aux
autres pays européens
je crois qu'il ya du pain sur la planche
pour la présidence française monsieur de
l'heure quand on entend que votre credo
on se dit que margaret thatcher a
beaucoup de travail à faire pour vous
contrer monsieur de leur merci beaucoup
merci
verdict attendu ce soir dans le procès
de la branche lyonnaise d'action directe
maître vergès assurer la défense compte
rendu de cette dernière audience avec
dominique verdeilhan 1h15 de plaidoirie
de maître vergès pour répondre à 11
heures de réquisitoire vous avez dit
monsieur l'avocat général clame le
défenseur du noyau dur d'action directe
que cette société il la juge pour y êtes
vous sûrs qu'ils sont les seuls à le
penser
tout au long de sa plaidoirie maître
vergès s'est efforcé de resituer le
combat d'action directe dans une
tradition
culturel de violence révolutionnaire de
1789 oblige pour maître vergès ce n'est
pas dans le code pénal que nous
trouverons la clé de leurs songes de
leur rêve d'une grande fraternité ce que
l'on cherche à condamner souligne
l'avocat ce ne sont pas les actes c'est
l'attachement des hommes à leurs idées
leur sincérité leur fidélité et maître
vergès d'achever sa plaidoirie en
s'adressant au président s'est redit ni
que pensons tous ceux qui suivent avec
attention ce procès d'une justice qui
amnistie des ministres et qui frappe les
plus passionnés de ses enfants après
quoi andré olivier s'enflammera
lorsqu'il évoquera le régime carcéral
dont il se dit victime ce que vous avez
fait à mes enfants à joël crapet vous le
paierez par votre mort ou par celle de
votre famille adresse-t-il violemment au
président s'est redit ni qui lui retire
aussitôt la parole
la cour d'assises spéciale de lyon s'est
retiré pour une longue délibération sans
surprise dans les locaux hospitalier de
la prison de fresnes les quatre membres
fondateurs d'action directe poursuivent
eux une grève de la faim qui en est à
son 70ème jour bavures policières ou
légitime défense c'est le débat
classique devant la cour d'assises du
val de marne à créteil le procès d'eric
laignel a commencé aujourd'hui
ce gardien de la paix avait abattu un
motard en juillet 1986 première audience
l'exposé des faits and gas burget la
première question vient du président
ligue ou accusé voulez vous nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé eric laniel
se lève il est blême
c'était le 31 juillet comme mon style et
puis il s'effondre en larmes en
murmurant je ne peux pas je ne peux pas
suspendue quelques minutes l'audience
reprend dans une atmosphère de malaise
la cour écoute
le jeune policier dérouler le fil de
cette soirée du 31 juillet un message à
police secours signalent un motard qui
pourrait être le voleur de sac à
l'arraché de fontenay la police le
traquent depuis deux ans en vain rue du
clos d'orléans le policier laignel ici
lors de la reconstitution tentent
d'interpeller le motard qui surgit à
contresens
tout va très vite william normand roule
sur le trottoir il tente d'échapper à
laignel qui tire le motard s'effondre
tué d'une balle dans le dos il a fait un
geste menaçant j'ai eu peur j'ai cru
qu'ils étaient armés a dit
d'après midi le policier mais aucune
arme n'a été retrouvée ni sur le corps
ni chez la victime depuis trois ans sa
famille attend des explications
on est des petits où on est des petits
les flics ces débats là ils sont grands
il ya près de justice et on est des
potirons à la barre aujourd'hui trois
témoins venus soutenir leur collègue
policier témoignages pourtant
contradictoires endroit où le policier
daniel prétend avoir rabattu les clients
et largement contredit par d'autres
déclarations etc déclare-t-il
correspondent aux constatations
matérielles donc il est fort probable
que la réalité soit que les l'endroit où
mon client a été abattu et un endroit
qui lui a interdit d'avoir commis le
moindre geste menaçant ce motta et
d'être extrêmement dangereux voilà ce
que je veux dire de cet après midi la
famille réclame une peine exemplaire le
policier lui a répété qu'il n'a pas visé
qu'il ne pourra jamais expliquer comment
le coup est parti
comme je vous disais hier le coup de
pouce gouvernemental au smic et de 1,9
pour cent le smic sera samedi 1er
juillet à 5000 54 francs et 79 centimes
pour les syndicats dans leur grande
majorité cette hausse n'est que
symbolique
la suite de l'actualité en france avec
des informaticiens qui menacent de ne
pas informatisé les résultats du bac
éric perrin
les informaticiens de l'éducation
nationale menacent de bloquer les notes
du baccalauréat dans certaines académies
leur coordination nationale exige
l'ouverture immédiate de négociations en
vue d'un rattrapage salarial
une délégation sera reçue demain au
ministère de l'éducation nationale
près d'un millier de mineurs des
potasses d'alsace en grève illimitée
depuis le 8 juin dans les rues de paris
reçus cet après midi au ministère de
l'industrie les grévistes réclament un
rattrapage de 1200 francs par mois pour
tous le ministre de l'industrie roger
courroux estime que ces revendications
devraient être abaissés à un niveau
raisonnable
le syndicat national des pilotes de
ligne suspend son appel à la grève de 24
heures prévue pour le 1er juillet le
snpl a indiqué qu'il avait obtenu du
ministère des transports des assurances
sur les points litigieux
l'état propose plus de 100 millions de
francs pour le rachat des sites des
chantiers navals de la ciotat et de la
seyne sur mer
cette offre est en compétition avec deux
autres propositions l'une émanant de la
société dumez l'autre du groupe tapie
le tribunal de commerce de paris
pourrait prendre sa décision au début du
mois de juillet la réglementation
concernant les jouets et les articles de
puériculture les portes de garage
basculantes les parcs aquatiques les
pétards et les feux d'artifice sera plus
draconiennes c'est une décision du
conseil des ministres pour faire
diminuer le nombre des acides des
accidents domestiques qui font en france
chaque année
vingt-deux mille morts d'orbis et qui
gorby c'est quoi tenez aujourd'hui deux
informations qui illustre le nouveau
cours en union soviétique
le cachet de la poste fait foi pour un
télégramme de félicitations envoyé par
gorbatchev au nouveau secrétaire général
du parti communiste chinois
avec quatre jours de retard il y a
grogne diplomatique
à moscou on annonce deuxième chose le
licenciement de 25 mille policiers pour
incompétence
gorbatchev ça se mesure donc au
quotidien et aura du pavé vous le verrez
ce soir à 22h15 sur antenne 2 dans le
magazine qu'on réalise et bruno albin
jean-marie lequertier et michel tournay
extraits
à ce jour aucun journaliste soviétique
n'a su répondre à cette question
pourquoi 130 enfants de 4 à 14 ans il
soudain perdu leurs cheveux en octobre
l'année dernière en ukraine
maman me peiné tout à coup elle a trouvé
beaucoup de cheveux sur la brosse pas
ton combat maman elle a changé de brasse
ou appliquée elle s'est aperçue que tous
mes cheveux restent déçus non ça je
prenais mon bain mais m'en voulais
savoir si je m'étais bien l'avouer la
tête
mes cheveux sont restés dans sa main et
mes cheveux sont restés dans sa masse
ses instincts
l' enquête piétine depuis des mois en
janvier les cheveux ont repoussé mais
sans que l'on sache vraiment pourquoi le
soviet municipale fait ce qu'il peut
mais il craque une pollution dans
personne ne lui a encore dit le nom dans
le sang des enfants malades
les analyses montrent la présence d'un
métalloïdes le bord mais aucune usine de
la région dont utilisent les
spécialistes venus de toute l'urss et
des pays-bas n'explique pas la maladie
il l'a constate bien que les cheveux et
repousser certains enfants n'ont pas pu
retourner à l'école ils sont soignés à
domicile
max il se plaint de douleurs dans la
colonne vertébrale et dans les membres
il fait partie des enfants qui ne sont
pas encore guéris
maxime est anormalement nerveux et dort
très mal certaines petites filles ont
coupé les cheveux de leurs poupées
et bastia a repris son piano mais il est
resté des mois enfermé chez lui
évidemment chaque maire craint pour
l'avenir de son enfant
on voudrait croire qu'il s'agit
seulement des cheveux c'est que le reste
n'a pas été touché ce que les organes et
l'appareil moteur n'ont pas été atteints
on voudrait bien le croire
cros et à l'hôpital
le défilé continue certains enfants sur
note encore leurs cheveux par plaques
pour stimuler leur défense les médecins
les soumettent à un régime alimentaire
très nutritif accompagnés d'exercices
physiques
il ya des mensonges point qu'aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas encore le droit moral
de dire que ces enfants sont guéris à
1500 kilomètres de là en estonie le même
mal vient de frapper 300 enfants
là encore aucune explication
de nombreux autres cas sont signalés sur
la volga accueille beat chef tout aussi
mystérieux
quelqu'un quelque part ne dit pas ce
qu'il sait
ce magazine de la rédaction d'antenne 2
a pour titre sous le regard de lénine
c'est tout à l'heure à 22h15 moscou
toujours pour la première fois un haut
responsable du kgb donne plus que des
détails sur un transfuge américain et
sur sa mort le 20 juin dernier
ce n'est pas dans la tradition du
renseignement hervé brusini dans la
clandestinité il se nommait michael
green sol citoyens américains militaires
de l'us navy
aujourd'hui le voilà devenu mirail f
gagné beach orlov
héros du kgb sa notice nécrologique est
à la une de l'étoile rouge le quotidien
de l'armée soviétique exalte la bravoure
de l'espion nicolaï gerasimov lui-même
le porte parole du ministère des
affaires étrangères a précisé l'identité
d'orlov et son grade majeur dans le kgb
claironné a ainsi les états de service
d'une taupe
bizarre bizarre s'interrogent les
spécialistes occidentaux car c'est une
règle jamais on dévoile l'existence d'un
agent orlov lui est une exception de
taille
l'année dernière le public soviétique
l'a vu à la télévision faire le récit de
ses exploits d'hommes de l'ombre
il racontait comment il espionné les
militaires américains depuis orlov s'est
suicidé sener était trop fragile du toit
moscou à présent l'urss s'apprête à
publier les notes personnelles du fidèle
agent un raz-de-marée d'information à
perspective même après sa mort orlov
demeure une arme comme si l'on cherchait
à déstabiliser l'autre comme si l'état
major du kgb avait en ce moment même
quelques comptes à régler avec une
puissance adverse
demain à la fête du cinéma et plus de
deux millions de spectateurs attendus
dans les salles pour 35 francs autant de
séances que vous le désirez le cinéma
français qui semble aller un tout petit
peu mieux
jean jacques dufour en un siècle le
cinéma l'industrie du 7e art a évolué et
bien évidemment ce n'est plus la même
chose que dans les années 50 époque à
laquelle se réfère cet extrait de cinéma
paradisio l'un des événements du dernier
festival de cannes france l année là en
france il y avait plus de 400 millions
de spectateurs contre à peine 122
millions
l'année dernière heureusement le cinoche
fait toujours rêver et ces chiffres ne
désespère pas les professionnels car
l'année 89 semble amorcer une reprise au
mois il n'y a jamais eu de fatalité à la
crise j'ai toujours tenté de me battre
contre cette idée de fatalité je crois
qu'on peut changer les choses
à condition de s'en donner la peine est
de se battre pour le faire effectivement
les chiffres du premier trimestre 89
devrait redonner le sourire aux
professionnels
en effet la fréquentation des salles a
augmenté de 11% et les recettes de 15%
de quoi dérider des professionnels dont
le visage barré du mot crise commençait
à ressembler à celui de joux baie
lorsqu'il perdait au baccarat formidable
mais je crois que c'est dû surtout au
travail qui a été fait par les
professeurs de cinéma depuis deux trois
ans qui ont fait que les films viennent
quand même du mieux en mieux et qui
avant l'homme ont une vraie complicité
entre le public et les gens de cinéma
la crise c'est surtout pour les mauvais
films
les chiffres le montrent les productions
de qualité attire toujours des
spectateurs avides d'histoires
elle tout le lido beaux stades à la
moneda leur retard
pas le panier demain pour la fête du
cinéma et moyennant l'achat d'un premier
billet plein tarif vous pourrez ensuite
vous en livrer gratuitement de pellicule
un rêve non non signature wimbledon avec
aujourd'hui une surprise brad gilbert la
tête de série numéro 11 a été éliminé
par l'australien fitzgerald troisième
jour donc avec aujourd'hui comme tête
d'affiche sanchez et lendl notamment
gens meurent tout se passe bien ce début
de tournoi pourra rendre 513 le
vainqueur de roland garros face à la
tchécoslovaquie jahn ap auspices olow à
elle à jouer son tennis physique de la
terre battue avec parfois quelques
finesses
cela a payé en deux sets
elle s'est aisément qualifié pour
affronter au tour suivant la française
julie halard le suédois batman 200 91e
joueur mondial a en revanche posé
quelques problèmes au fantomatique
länder un premier set perdu puis trois
sets aux scores flatteurs mais qui ne
sont pas le reflet du tennis laborieux
d'ivan lendl
sauvé par son service ivan lendl n'a pas
encore trouvé le bon rythme heureusement
pour lui les adversaires rencontrés lui
permet encore de passer de temps en
temps à côté du problème
pour terminer un conseil de lecture un
inédit de boris vian chez christian
bourgois
ça s'appelle rude et ravissante
publication intéressante il y a trente
ans que l'auteur de l'écumé des jours
est mort oui parade des moins de 25 ans
boris vian est toujours le plus lu avec
camus largement devant malraux et sartre
fin de ce journal dans un instant la
météo avec sophie davant 22h15 sous le
regard de méline bruno albin jean-marie
lequertier pour la dernière édition à
23h20 henri sannier à demain 20h
excellente soirée à tous
à